PETA wants us to stop bringing home the
bacon and start bringing home the bagels
no more can we beat a dead horse
now we must feed a fed orce we will
analyze how left-wing vegans want to
destroy language with vegan friendly
idioms presumably because there are a
few fries short of a happy meal then Bob
Dole and Alan Simpson dazzle at George
Bush's funeral a never Trump magazine
goes under and a brand new maggot dating
app I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I wonder how many more idioms we can
break out there they you can lead a
horse to water but you can only
force-feed a goose to give you a flood
ride or no there very many and PETA is
going after it PETA and some left-wing
academics we will analyse why the left
is always trying to control our words
and to control our culture but first do
you know what time it is it's time for
you to do all of your holiday shopping
and how are you gonna know the time
using movement you know how much I love
movement with the holiday season coming
gifting is easy with movements versatile
line of watches classes and accessories
I have never gotten more compliments on
any watch than I do on my movement watch
this is the revolver atlas it is super
cool if you're looking to get me a gift
for Christmas
get me the new arc line its movements
new automatic mechanical watch it's
beautiful beautiful technology beautiful
mechanism inside and it looks really
sleek as do all of their products
they're all about looking good while
keeping it simple it's a grand up
entrepreneur story its crowd funded by
these two college dropouts now they've
sold a million and a half watches in
over a 160 countries movement watches
start at just 95 bucks if you were in a
department store four hundred five
hundred dollars especially when you're
talking about these automatic watches
the new arc line so nice movement did
all the hard work this holiday season so
you don't have to they may they have
also awesome gift boxes and packages I
am giving people on my list movement
watches I am paying money I am not only
a kalaiy entombment I'm also a regular
customer
they've curated all of their favorite
styles into special gift boxes for you
so you can absolutely crush it this
holiday season without the added stress
15% off today free shipping and free
returns go to MVM t-dot-com slash cough
fa co v fe e fe e movements launching
new styles on their site all the time
movement calm / cough fa m VMT calm /
cough fa join the movement join the
movement how long before we're gonna
have to start changing all of these
words to their we have to change all of
the words this is the new line coming
out of peta and left-wing academics this
from sharina's e hamza an academic from
swan saya
university you know that's where i get
all of my tips about the
english-language expressions this one
say a university this is what they're
saying quote the
increased awareness of vegan issues will
filter through consciousness to produce
new modes of expression it may very well
be that down the line powerful meat
metaphors are issued what are the meat
metaphors bringing home the bacon we're
not allowed to use bringing home the
bacon anymore we're supposed to say
bringing home the bagels the other one
is putting all your eggs in one basket
it's not just animals we're not allowed
to reference animals we're not even
allowed to reference animal products so
you can't say putting all of your eggs
in one basket another one is killing two
birds with one stone you're not you
can't say that it's about killing Birds
that's terrible and it isn't just one
wacko academic if it were one wacko
academic saying this I would say oh go
to kind of laugh it off I mean that's
what academics do is they say crazy
things and we ignore them but a PETA
People for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals is now tweeting about this by
the way PETA is the most ironically
named organization probably in the
country PETA for the Ethical Treatment
of Animals has killed in the last two
decades just about 96 percent of the
animals in their care on any given year
the animals in their care this is well
over 30,000 animals since 1998 96
percent of them are killed by PETA even
the ones that could be adopted out they
just killed them but they call it People
for the Ethical Treatment of Animals so
they sent out a tweet yesterday it's
catching a ton of interest online the
tweet red stopped using anti animal
language and this is this is the money
line just as it became unacceptable to
use racist homophobic or ableist
language phrases that trivialize cruelty
to animals will vanish as more people
begin to appreciate animals for who they
are and start bringing home the bagels
instead of the bacon quote words matter
and as our understanding of social
justice evolves our language evolves
along with it this is my thesis on the
culture is that the left uses language
to affect their political agenda so by
the time we get to the political fight
we've already lost because they've
already changed the language through the
culture this is what political
correctness is they use terms like
social justice
what what is social justice what they're
using social justice as a as a stand-in
for is morality they're saying that we
now in our enlightened moral standards
realize that it's wrong to kill animals
it's wrong to eat animals it's wrong to
wear animal skins and use leather and
whatever how is that where is that where
do we find that in any sane moral
standard whoo I know that they say it I
know that these wacko lefties say it but
where do we find it the trouble with
these new suggestions by the way is that
the new idioms don't make any sense so
the new way of bringing home the bagels
okay I guess that that one's the most
defensible of them putting all your eggs
in one basket they now want us to say
putting all your berries in one basket
that doesn't make any sense if you've
got all your eggs in one basket you drop
the basket all your eggs are gone
because you crack the egg and then
they're gone if you put all your berries
in your basket then you drop the basket
nothing happens
they're berries berries are pretty
pretty durable you drop them you pick
them up you and eat them dust them off
that's fine same thing with beating a
dead horse that idiom makes sense
feeding a fed horse doesn't make any
sense there's another famous idiom you
can lead a horse to water but you can't
make it drink so they're getting very
confused about all of their all of their
idioms and then my favorite one they
took to kill two birds with one stone
and they want to change it to feed two
birds with one scone so you get it you
have a scone and you feed two birds that
one doesn't make any sense though
because it is difficult to kill two
birds with one stone
it's tactically difficult and what what
you were saying with that idiom is that
you're going to be efficient in your use
of tactics you're gonna take care of two
things in one fell swoop in an efficient
way where it would usually it only take
care of one thing to feed two birds with
one scone is very easy because birds
don't eat very much you could feed a
hundred birds with one scone that
doesn't mean anything it's so absurd but
they're changing this language and that
the issue here is is the language I
don't really care about the rise of
veganism although it is a little weird
veganism is up 360 percent in the UK
over the last decade it's up 500% in the
over just the last four years and the
issue with veganism the reason they're
so whacked out about the language here
is that veganism is a morally incoherent
ideology veganism you can't it's not
just that you can't eat animals you
can't eat fish you can't eat shellfish
and you can't even eat animal products
you can't eat milk
you can't drink milk you can't eat eggs
and my question is why stop there does
anyone really believe that an oyster is
more conscious than a carrot I was I was
on Fox News this morning talking about
this very topic and I got actually a lot
of letters and tweets and things in not
just from left-wingers but from
right-wingers too who say oh Michael
you're being too harsh I'm a vegetarian
I'm a vegan and it's so much better and
it's so much more moral we have to set
the record straight here a an oyster is
not in any way more conscious than a
carrot they are morally identical
entities why is it okay to eat the
carrot but they're but it's okay to get
the care but not eat the oyster and
further I mean the big example here is
abortion because every vegan I know
every single one I know a number of
vegans and I've had to sit through
terrible lunches when they take me out
to them they're all in favor of abortion
so there so they weep for the little cat
Easter they weep for the delta smelt but
an unborn human baby it doesn't matter
wipe it out kill it it that is a morally
incoherent idea and what it does is it
inverts the natural order so we have a
natural order of things the animals are
here we have dominion over them and they
are here for our enjoyment so this is
why we don't want to torture animals we
don't want to be cruel to animals but
the reason that we shouldn't torture
animals or be cruel to animals is not
because the animals have some rights
some consciousness some spiritual life
some soul or anything like that the
reason that we shouldn't be cruel to
animals is because it deadens our
compassion it deadens our humanity to be
needlessly cruel to some innocent little
animal the the reason that we need to
conserve animals is not because animals
are good and humans are bad or that
animals have some right to exist in
nature and you know prance around the
forests it's so that we can enjoy them
the reason to conserve the deer
is so that we can go kill more deer you
know hunt them and have a good time
there was just there was a wolf that was
killed in I think it was Yellowstone and
this was a major Twitter moment you know
this made headlines all around and they
said a beloved wolf was killed by a
trophy hunter now the wolf was killed
legally he had a license to go kill the
wolf
they say the beloved wolf beloved by
whom who is crying over the wolf they
did this when a guy bought a very
expensive permit that dentist to go kill
Cecil the lion in Africa and they said
he was a beloved lion beloved by whom
it's not a beloved lion he's a lion
there and actually the reason that they
sell permits to these trophy hunters is
because they cost a lot of money and
then all of that money is put toward
conservation efforts being levied by
whom they're just crafting this
narrative to tug on your heartstrings
also last time I checked Cecil is not a
particularly African name they're trying
to make it sound like it's the Lion King
or something this beautiful natural
environment no not quite
I guess the dentist killed the wrong
lion or something but come on give me a
break
so this this inversion is very very
strange and it's true of the entire
environmentalist left they think that we
are here to serve animals too which is
true only in the sense that we serve
them on our dinner plates we are here to
conserve them and then serve them to
each other
because they taste very good but we are
not here to to give them honor or to
give them fealty or anything like that
they are here for us and we love them
because they provide a lot of nice
things for us like a good veal Picatta
on a good Saturday night but that's it
that's where the line is and they've
exactly flipped that order the left does
this all the time they're constantly
flipping and inverting major issues you
know I love Orrin Hatch a Republican
senator he celebrated Peter's tweed in
precisely the right way here's orrin
hatch
[Music]
oh yeah Oh getting me getting my hunger
up I was at a wedding in in New York
over the weekend and the wedding was
held at the Harvard club and the the one
cool thing that the Harvard club has
that other clubs don't have is they have
a giant elephant head on the wall but
and actually I'm I'm a little nervous
about this because in my my you know
elephants might demonstrate certain
aspects of consciousness so I'm a little
a little iffy on it but still we get to
honor this cool elephant head on the
wall it's being enjoyed so much more
than if it were just ravaged by some
predator in its natural environment we
have we have more nature worship more
bizarre left-wing nature worship which
is torching the streets of Paris right
now and it's even even being heralded by
Arnold Schwarzenegger the Terminator at
the UN but first let's talk about
something really really nice and
comfortable Boland branch sheets we are
never gonna agree on everything but we
can agree we could all use more sleep I
only got about 18 hours last night
because I had to wake up early for that
TV show so don't don't be like me
luckily you can maximize your sleep
using Boleyn branch sheets I love these
sheets I also am a customer of these
sheets I give them out to friends and
relatives everything Boleyn branch makes
from bedding to blankets is made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
they start out super soft and they get
even softer over time you can buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying a wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store Boleyn brand sheets are only a
couple hundred bucks they feel
absolutely incredible they feel
categorically different than the cheap
sheets that you bought at your local
store three u.s. presidents sleep on
Boland branch sheets there's a reason
for that one blank book best-selling
author also sleeps on those sheets
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund you will not want to
send them back I'm telling you no risk
no reason not to give them a try the
trouble with my sponsors is I love them
so much that I just spend a bunch of
money buying their products and Poland
branch is one of them to get started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at Boleyn
branch kaam promo code Michel mi CH AE L
bowl
branch comm today 50 bucks off your
first set of siege sheets say that seven
times fast Bo ll and branch comm promo
code Michael mich a e l that is the that
is the natural order is lying down on
those comfy sheets the inverting the
natural order is this bizarre nature
worship and we're seeing this now from
Arnold Schwarzenegger he was at a UN
climate conference in Poland and he said
that if he could he would time travel
travel back in time to terminate fossil
fuels which is such that is the most
privileged elitist decadent thing I've
ever heard because it's true Arnold
Schwarzenegger living in a zillion
dollar mansion he doesn't think about
what oil and fossil fuels to fossil
fuels eliminated poverty fossil fuels
and free-market capitalism has virtually
eliminated poverty around the world it
is lifted so many people out of poverty
it fossil fuels is is the magic that is
the magic thing that allows for industry
it allows for people to be mobile to
travel enormous distances virtually
immediately it allows for people to heat
their homes to cook their food it is it
is so essential to raising people from
dire extreme poverty into a good
standard of living but people who are
resilient heirs elitists like Al Gore or
Arnold Schwarzenegger they write all of
that off and imagine this he says quote
the biggest evil is fossil fuels it's
coal it's gasoline
it's natural gas that that is the point
that is what they're all saying that
pollution carbon dioxide fossil fuels
are evil and the reason that they have
to make fossil fuels evil and they have
to pretend that is because they want to
feel morally virtuous but they're not
virtuous people so they say if this is
the greatest evil does anyone really
believe the greatest evil is gasoline if
that's the greatest evil stop using
gasoline do I assume you use gasoline I
assume you get on airplanes I assume you
drive your car I assume you take trains
and heat turn your lights on and I
assume you use fossil fuels if you
really need the greatest evil stop it
but of course it's not the greatest evil
the imagination of man's heart is evil
from the beginning
we know that there is a natural original
sin in us I don't know what what are
some things that are more evil than
gasoline murder for one rape fraud
adultery infanticide that's another why
guess that's under murder what else what
theft burglary aggravated assault many
things are more evil than them than
gasoline gasoline isn't evil at all but
what these pit I talk to people in
Hollywood and it becomes this bizarre
obsession for Hollywood types who are
usually hollowed out on the inside these
are people who do bad things all the
time their lives are a wreck
I mean eat the secret is especially for
actors even a list actors very
successful actors most of them are
miserable and they're miserable because
they're not working very much even if
you're working all the time you're still
not working that much in the arts in
Hollywood and so you've got all of this
free time it's virtually impossible to
sustain a marriage in show business in
industries that Arnold Schwarzenegger
has been in it's virtually impossible to
act in a moral productive good virtuous
way it just does not happen a lot and so
people feel this brokenness and they
feel this need to be virtuous but they
don't want to actually practice virtue
so they they practice a pantomime of
virtue which is what environmentalism is
environmentalism is a separate religious
system it's a parallel religious system
to our traditional religions like
Christianity or Judaism and they there
it has indulgences you can buy
indulgences in the form of carbon tax
credits it has sin which original sin
which is pollution it has atonement in
the in the form of recycling or in the
form of reducing your use of fossil
fuels
it has proselytizers like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Al Gore and it offers
them a sense of getting off the hook for
their real moral failings by pretending
to act virtuously and to reject false
moral failings like using gasoline is
it's really sad to watch it but the more
that people stop paying attention to
them their metaphysical selves to their
souls they're going to pay attention to
these
sickle pantomimes a virtue and that that
is the environmental movement now if you
want to look at actual virtue if you
want to look at real men practicing
virtue look no further than the funeral
for george w bush or but pardon
god forbid not for a long time george HW
bush bush senior he was he's being laid
to rest there was a big beautiful
funeral in the National Cathedral today
president Crump attended and there was a
great moment yesterday when Bob Dole a
United States Senator 1996 GOP nominee
for president went was wheeled up there
and while just show you the video I'm
narrated as it goes along Bob Dole goes
right up he's alone in front of the
casket the American flag draped over it
and his guard physically lifts Bob Dole
out of his wheelchair he's so frail and
he's he stares at the coffin he raises
his left arm and he salutes President
Bush and then he he stands there and
then his guard sits him back down and
this is such a beautiful moment but you
might be asking first of all why did Bob
Dole salute with his left hand he
saluted with his left hand because Bob
Dole served in World War two with the
10th Mountain Division and he got gunned
up by a German machine gun in Italy in
the OP anaemia mountains and it got his
back and it took down much of his right
arm sling I mean just a riddle of
bullets down it so he had very very
limited use of his right arm he was he
was really severely injured and he came
back they said at the time they quote
they they gave him the largest dose of
morphine they dared and they wrote M for
morphine on his forehead in his own
blood so that nobody else who found him
would give him a second dose of morphine
which would have killed him this is a
Bob Dole I really love this guy even
though he was sort of a a moderate
Republican or a liberal Republican he
ran in 76 for Vice President with Gerald
Ford he ran for the presidency in 1980
against Ronald Reagan and George Bush he
ran again in 1988 against George Bush
same guy who just he just saluted he won
the nomination finally in 96
the first President presidential
candidate that I really loved my first
campaign that I ever volunteered on was
to campaign for Bob Dole in my
first-grade classroom I tried to
convince all my friends to get their
parents to vote for Bob Dole we wasn't a
terribly exciting candidate and he lost
ultimately to Bill Clinton but he also
Bob Dole came back around he was the
only GOP former nominee to endorse
Donald Trump in 2016
bush senior wouldn't do it Bush jr.
wouldn't do it John McCain wouldn't do
it only Bob Dole came around and did it
and then there's Bob Dole there saluting
George Bush George Bush who himself was
the youngest Navy pilot during World War
two he was shot down he heroically
survived I bring this up to show a
little episode of virtue of a duty of
loyalty of overcoming political
differences of a genuine bond between
these men and just to remind you that
the Democrats forced us to have
President Bill Clinton over George Bush
and Bob Dole to virtuous men they they
rejected those virtuous men twice in a
row for a draft-dodging degenerate
possible rapist Bill Clinton that's what
happened and so now you know we talk
about civility you know we talk about
restoring honor to the White House to
the Oval Office how awful Trump is look
at those two men even if you didn't love
their politics George Bush was kind of a
moderate squishy Republican Bob Dole
same thing but there were loyal
Republicans they were good guys and they
were loyal Americans who fought for
their country who were wounded for their
country and and we had to deal with
Bubba Clinton who ran away like a coward
to avoid the draft so that it was a
beautiful part of the ceremony then Alan
Simpson gets up there the the former GOP
senator Alan Simpson I think he's about
115 years old at this point he he gets
up there and delivers one of the best
eulogies I've ever seen here just a few
clips George told me I only had 10
minutes
he was very direct about it it wasn't
even funny
it's for our country that I have fought
for and he was a man of such great
humility those who travel the high road
of humility in Washington DC are not
bothered by heavy traffic he never hated
anyone he knew what his mother and my
mother always knew hatred corrodes the
container it's carried in such powerful
words in such a powerful eulogy that
touches on so many points what I really
loved about Allen Simpsons eulogy here
is that it was delivered with strength
and with balance and with humor and with
the seriousness and with sincerity and
with earnestness it really took the life
of George Bush and it really took a view
of life and a life well-lived that we
could all learn from it had these first
of all hatred corrodes the container it
is carried in such a state Minh Thuy
have to remember his people I can't
believe it when I go to these campuses
where I look on Twitter or something
how vitriolic and angry and nasty and
mean people can be and look I love
owning the libs
I love taking the fight to the left wing
and pushing really hard and never giving
back and punching right back and not
being a squish I love all of that you've
got to do it with a bit of humor if you
are getting angry all the time and and
irritated and you hate people and you're
doing politics wrong get out of politics
do something else you are not that this
is not the place for you then if you're
gonna really hate people and get so
riled up all the time and the reason for
that is not because the other guy
doesn't deserve it
there are plenty of people who deserve
our scorn and our derision and our anger
and and our righteous anger though the
reason not to become filled with hatred
is because hatred hurts you it corrodes
you it is not what what goes into the
mouth that defiles a man but what comes
out of the mouth sometimes you say
things that can't be unsaid and it's so
vile and corrosive to what you are and
that's why alan simpson rejected it and
george bush to george bush and plenty of
others something really we could learn
from but
even the view of this Alan Simpson I
guess in 2012 George Bush they had been
friends for decades and decades I think
they'd been friends since the 60s and
George Bush thought he might be dying in
2012 and the Bush family asked Alan
Simpson
to give the eulogy and that was when
they said they said to him all right
Alan you only get 10 minutes now more
than 10 minutes so keep it keep it short
but apparently at that same time Bush
said I want you to cry when you write
the eulogy so that you don't cry well
you say the eulogy the very important
advice I see this in I've given eulogies
I've given best man toasts I've you know
and I think we've all given some version
of these things that we have to say in
public at events either joyful events or
bittersweet events or sad events and
they're they're very tricky things to
write they're much trickier than giving
a podcast or a lecture or something like
that because they have to take a bigger
view a broader view of the human life
and a lot of times I've seen eulogies
where people are weeping and sobbing and
they're angry and they're cursing or you
can tell that they want to be cursing
and this isn't oh this isn't right you
know what Alan Simpson is showing us is
that George Bush lived a life well he
did what he came here to do he served
others he served his country he was
dignified when his country threw him out
of office
he was always graceful always tactful
and he lived to be 94 there's nothing to
be angry and sad about we were talking a
little while ago a few days ago about
how confused we all are about death
these days we're trying to cure death in
Silicon Valley and do anything we can to
extend life even one moment further
we're so afraid of natural death I don't
think George Bush was afraid of natural
death I think George Bush looked forward
to seeing his wife and daughter again
his daughter Robin who died decades and
decades ago I think he was looking
forward to it not not that he was
despondent not that he was despairing
they wanted to kill himself but he was
ready to go meet his maker to his home
in eternity to hit to have his just
reward for a life well-lived
the trouble with a country that is
increasingly atheistic is that it's a
country that increasingly is full of
despair we see this reflected in drug
addiction and we see this reflected in
suicides both of which are surging
beyond beyond the imagination that's
what happens in a country without hope
with despair but there is hope and you
can see it when when you die when a life
well-lived in a life where you you have
hope in in heaven and in your savior
then you get to go somewhere else I
remember during when those Dallas police
officers were killed a few years ago
there was an attack on Dallas police
officers George Bush went there and he
he was singing along he was swaying to I
think was the Battle Hymn of the
Republic mine eyes have seen the glory
of the coming of the Lord
his truth is marching on and George Bush
was kind of happy they said this was
inappropriate that he was happy in a
funeral but he was happy because he
believed it he believed that the glory
of the Lord was there and that and the
truth was there and the truth goes
marching on and we should believe it too
it certainly seems George Bush did and
Alan Simpson did kept that balance of
the human life and we should always try
to keep that balance in times of great
celebration and in times of bittersweet
even sadness while we say goodbye to
somebody really well done we could all
learn a lot from those guys now speaking
speaking of of protecting your life and
a life well-lived you got to talk about
Brownells Brownells is a big proponent
supporter of the Second Amendment and
they have been for nearly 80 years this
is Verint when you want to protect your
life and your liberty you need to make
sure that you exercise your rights and
your right to bear arms that will allow
you to do that but you're buying guns
ammo accessories online it is convenient
it is totally legal and I know that if
you're watching this show you you or
your friends or family probably would
love to open up a Brownells gift card
for Christmas there are a lot of new
people coming in or taking interest in
firearms young people women people
living in the cities there was after
that shooting at the gay nightclub in in
Orlando there were a bunch of signs that
went up around the country that said on
a rainbow
like it said we fight back and a huge
surge in in demographics that
traditionally have not had an interest
in firearms who realize we need to
protect ourselves
Brownells is the world's leading
supplier of firearms ammunition firearm
accessories reloading components and
more they offer an industry exclusive
guaranteed forever warranty on all parts
and accessories
offers nearly a hundred twenty thousand
items from guns and ammo to nearly any
gun part imaginable has more than 5,500
partner FFL around the country to make
your online gun purchase go smoothly
it's family owned and veteran owned
they've been doing business in the
country's heartland of Iowa for nearly
80 years do not forget about the gun guy
or gun gal on your Christmas list like
me send me one of these gift cards wish
me a Merry Christmas please brownells
gift cards make great stocking stuffers
go to brownells.com and put some freedom
in it your loved ones Christmas like me
like your beloved Michael send me a gift
card I want to buy more firearms and
firearm accessories so a really
beautiful eulogy is all around George W
Bush George Bush's son former president
also gave a beautiful eulogy as well so
that's the right note that's the right
note to hit during all of these funerals
how about the wrong note who could take
a dignified beautiful expression coming
together in in a little bit of grief but
in a happiness and joy at a life
well-lived in a guy who served his
country
the Clintons of course watch as the
Clintons snubbed President Trump well he
sits down to the funeral areas he sits
down he shakes hands with brock obama
shakes hands with michelle obama
president Trump shaking the hands of the
Obamas the Clintons did not acknowledge
President Trump they won't even
acknowledge him Hillary they're looking
even colder than usual which I think
makes her about zero degrees Kelvin at
that point I think that basically is
what stops time and space entirely and
we you know as as cold as the universe
will tolerate and then there's bill next
to her who won't even look at him
which is really hard I think for Bill
Clinton because Bill Clinton's whole
persona is just being a really nice guy
hey there hey pass me that cigar
or what I'm gonna yep so that's but bill
is sitting there even he won't turn and
acknowledge Donald Trump that's fine
we're told by Democrats and by squishy
Republicans we want the good old days we
want to you know fight with the our
opponents and then go get drinks with
them at 6:00 p.m. we come we want
civility we were okay then lead then
lead on it there's Donald Trump trying
to be civil easy
have you heard what the Obamas have been
saying about Donald Trump recently
they've been calling him awful racist
bigoted terrible person he goes there
and shakes their hand and they politely
acknowledge him and shake his hand as
well not the Clintons they can't do it
because they had they believe in nothing
other than themselves they are just a
shameless solipsistic an egotistical
black hole of civility and and that's
them that's who the Democrats nominated
in 2016 nearly nominated in 2008 they
need to lead but they won't do it we've
got a lot more to get to we've got to
get to how this breakdown in civility
between the left and the right is a
leading to bad sex and to new dating
apps we also need to say goodbye to a
never Trump magazine which looks like
it's going under will try to analyze why
that is but if you are on daily wire
calm thank you much you keep the lights
on if you are not then go over to Daley
wire calm how much is it ten bucks a
month 100 hours for an annual membership
you get me you get the Andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
that's coming up tomorrow so get your
questions in you get to ask questions in
the conversation in the backstage and
you get another Kingdom I mean you get
all of this great stuff but this this is
what you need you need the leftist tears
tumblr there is a new study out it says
that young Republicans are having more
sex than young Democrats this is leading
to new dating apps this is leading to
the next story that we'll talk about but
just that can you imagine the tears that
must be provoked by that simple terrible
sad fact for the left get your leftist
ears tumblr before it's too late it's
it's the end it's the only way to safely
enjoy those leftist tears be safe be
safe about you won't catch any diseases
be very safe about enjoying this those
sad leftist tears go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
before we get to why the left is having
bad sex we need to say a Jew of probably
to a conservative magazine which has
taken a very negative anti never Trump
stance at the Weekly Standard the Weekly
Standard this is Bill crystals magazine
there was a major report came out today
it's been around for a long time it's
really one of the pillars of
conservative commentary and it looks
like it is going out of business this is
all about Donald Trump
this is 100% about Donald Trump the
Weekly Standard went to war with Donald
Trump and Donald Trump won I should
preface this and say I like Bill Kristol
personally Bill Kristol was the guy who
founded it and editor-at-large I really
like him personally he was a professor
of mine at a fellowship that I once did
he's helped me out on certain political
campaigns I think he's an intelligent
guy I listened to his podcast
conversations with Bill Kristol it's one
of my favorite podcasts he made a huge
mistake on Donald Trump he made a huge
mistake and the magazine made a huge
mistake and now the magazine is paying
for it and what they're specifically
paying for is not making the mistake
it's doubling down on it it's it's not
acknowledging their mistake and it's
having the readership question their
judgment that is exactly what's
happening to be fair there's a broader
trend that's going on right now in
certain online magazines Vice media
voxcom BuzzFeed you notice a trend line
here they're all left-wing outlets and
the Weekly Standard has taken it was a
right-wing out letting then it took this
very negative anti Trump stance now it
looks like the Weekly Standard is
joining them and it might not just be
that they're cutting staff it might be
that they're truly going under the
Weekly Standard for those who remember
it was founded in 1995 strong strongly
supportive of the Bush administration
and then a strong opponent of the Trump
administration the Weekly Standard says
it's not going out because of dwindling
subscribers they say there are more
nefarious forces at work it's hard to
believe that I just even look at the
attitudes of my own conservative friends
and myself the people I know who are
conservatives who constantly devouring
this stuff do
read The Weekly Standard anymore and
it's it's because of the judgement it's
because we're questioning their
judgement it's not just that one or two
of the editors hate Donald Trump and
point out all the flaws in Donald
Trump's character and administration
that's fine I read a lot of things that
are critical of Donald Trump it's that
they doubled down they they wouldn't
give it to him when he did things right
they wouldn't admit that they predicted
this guy would be a Democrat a left
winger and awful president he wouldn't
do any of the things he promised and he
has he's fulfilled more of his promises
than any president in the modern era
he's been more conservative than any
president in the modern era it's okay to
get that wrong what's not okay is not to
admit that you got it wrong and it took
them in these crazy directions Jonathan
last writing in the Weekly Standard
implied that Brett Kavanaugh was quote a
Supreme Court justice of questionable
moral worth he implied that in a weekly
does anyone really does anyone on the
left or the right really believe that
Brett Kavanaugh is some moral degenerate
no of course not there was an a totally
contrived attack against him with no
evidence whatsoever and Cavanaugh fought
it off and he won but some people became
so crazed by their opposition to Donald
Trump Trump derangement syndrome TDS
that they would even attack a guy like
Brett Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh a staff
secretary to President Bush a federal
judge for a dozen years if he's such a
moral degenerate why didn't you voice
that your feelings on that a little
sooner he was a an assistant to Ken
Starr during the Starr investigation
it's not like this is some new guy but
they really did this and so that what to
take away I don't want to beat up on the
Weekly Standard because I do like the
people there even though they've they've
made an error in judgment that what this
really is is a warning to other
magazines and other commentary outlets
in politics it's very easy to get things
wrong people always get things wrong you
know it's like on sports predictions you
go and you watch a bunch of sports
analysts and they make all of these
predictions about what's going to happen
in the football game and then none of
them happen and then they're all on TV
the next day making more predictions
that's fine I get it
you just have to at a certain point
correct your predictions to adhere with
reality
because if you get to a place where
everything that you are describing is
only true hypothetically or is only true
theoretically or is neglectful of
reality people are not going to tune in
they're not going to pay attention
anymore and that's unfortunately it
seems what's what's going on with at the
Weekly Standard and I hope that other
outlets on the right don't fall into
that same trap it's okay to be wrong
don't worry when you when you say that
the Conservatives fall into this too
because conservatives sometimes fall
into pessimism if you say that the whole
world is going to go to hell in a
handbasket and then things actually turn
out pretty well for the time being
that's a cause for celebration it's okay
to be celebrate the fact that you were
wrong I hope people do this and all of
those people all of those despondent
right-wingers I've got even more good
news for you you can now get laid I know
this is very good news there is a new
dating app just for right-wingers it's
it's called writer it's an online dating
app started by Christie Edwards Lawton
and this this app is only for
right-wingers only for people supportive
of right-wing politics and if a leftist
tries to join the app will sue you to
make sure that the lefties stay off and
it encourages really good behavior
apparently if you're on this app and you
go out on a date and the man doesn't pay
for the first date you can report the
guy and then there will be consequences
for him because they don't want squishy
vegan you know herbivore men to go and
and say that they want to go dutch on
their first date
the man's got to pay because this is a
right-wing app that's a beautiful thing
now why does this app need to exist I
should point out that actor I'm saying
that right-wingers can now get laid
that's a cause for celebration
Republicans are already having sex in a
much higher rate than Democrats this was
shown in a survey by skin condoms
millennial sex survey 77 percent of
young Republicans are apparently having
sex at least once per week that is
compared to 68 percent of Democrats so
sad too bad for you guys it's a lot of
fun this is what happens when you're
angry all the time
and you deny that the sexual difference
and you say that baby it's cold outside
is rapey and you say that men can't ever
kiss women this is the logical
consequence guys maybe you should think
about this before you allow yourself to
buy these absurd left-wing lines but why
does there need to be an exclusively
right-wing dating app the reason isn't
that right wingers only want to date
right-wingers that's not the reason at
all the reason is the Democrats won't
date right-wingers this is borne out by
a number of surveys according to one
recent survey eighty two this is a
survey of 4,000 people 82% of Democrats
said that they would not date a
Republican 82% vast majority that's
compared to just 43% of Republicans who
said that they would not date a Democrat
so that about half about half as many
Republicans say they wouldn't date a
Democrat as Democrats say they wouldn't
date a Republican and we know this too
because on the other dating apps tinder
grinder that's the gay one what the
bumble is the other one I hear about all
of these I unfortunately well for maybe
fortunately I missed online dating I was
already dating by the time online dating
really came around so I didn't I didn't
ever have to deal with all of this but
apparently in online dating apps the
majority of Republicans hide their
political affiliation so if it's asked
on OkCupid or whatever what your
political views are they hide it because
they know that Democrats won't date them
57% of Republicans hide their party 18%
of Democrats hide their party and and
the reason for this is because Democrats
on the culture the left-wing owns the
culture the culture makes it socially
unacceptable to be a conservative so if
you are a conservative you could lose
your job you could lose your reputation
you can lose your girlfriend you could
lose a lot of social standing so they
have to hide it the other reason is that
conservatives have other things to talk
about than politics on their first date
they might talk about anything from the
weather to sports to religion to how
good the soup is to whatever another
round of drinks or something but because
for the left politics is religion and
therefore it is culture and therefore it
politics dominates so much of the social
space it really
matters to them we know this from from
another number of surveys over the last
few years the left is much more likely
to unfriend right-wingers on social
media than right-wingers are to unfriend
left wingers so this makes it very
difficult for conservatives to get along
in the dating apps this is a great thing
I think they're gonna have a fun time
and it raises this question would you
date a Democrat if you're a Republican
or if you're a Democrat would you date a
Republican and my answer is yes for sure
of course I would and it's because one I
don't need to lead with politics I mean
my politics stem from my the way I see
the world and my culture and my reason
and my premises about metaphysics and
what the world is for and what our lives
are for my politics does come from that
but we can talk about other things I
understand why Democrats think what they
think broadly speaking I don't want to
sound like I'm being prideful or
something I think basically I understand
why some left wingers support abortion
or support high taxes or want socialist
health care I think I basically get
their arguments but as John Hite pointed
out in in his work a number of years ago
the left broadly doesn't understand
conservatives so they don't really
understand where we're coming from so if
you say if you if we were on a date and
some Democrat says well I am a Democrat
I might laugh I might think okay that's
cute
we'll talk for a few few weeks and then
we'll see if you're still a Democrat
yeah have another drink yeah let's let's
talk about the basis of your ideas and
it would be interesting and by the way
if some girl doesn't change your ideas
that's fine we can learn from each other
we can have diversity of thought we know
that conservatives appreciate diversity
of thought much more but the same is not
true of the left so unfortunately now
we've got to totally segregate ourselves
by politics it's really shallow because
it does make an idol of politics I think
the app is a good idea I think it's a
good idea because the the left has made
us do it it's sort of like in war if you
say well I'm opposed to war I'm not
going to ever go to war and then some
other nation declares war on you the
other nation has a say
- you're not the only one who gets to
decide if you're at war the other nation
has a say - and so Republicans and
conservatives can say well I'm I want to
date people on the other side of the
aisle but if the other side of the aisle
says they won't date you then they have
a say in that - it's not it's not just
about what you want it's about what they
want so it seems like a good app but it
seems like a bad sign for our culture
and maybe in the spirit of the season of
unity of coming together go out and date
a Democrat go see if you can spread
spread a little romantic joy this
holiday season let me know how it works
out if not you've always got writer
there to go and you can swipe a write
write write write some more all right
that's our show a lot more to get to but
too late to bed put your mailbag
questions in the mailbag so that we can
answer them tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018